[Music]
my name is Andrew Sullivan I am a
product manager here in the Bay Area out
of Sunnyvale 4G suite security and I'm
joined by Pascal Ryan and red Pascal
hello everybody hello everybody my name
is Pascal editor and I've been working
at valia for two years and a half my
role is a head of technology office the
team basically deals with cyber security
software asset management enterprise
architecture and design Authority the
early edges few words about it it's a
large group company hundred and sixty
thousand people are working there and we
are focusing basically on three major
businesses water distribution West
recycling and energy guys I'm the
director of IT we oversee all corporate
IT retail IT as well a little bit about
Casper we are a disruptor in the
mattress industry direct to consumer or
three commerce and recently
brick-and-mortar and usually when a
Casper at least what we do is when we
introduce a new person we do a fun fact
so I'm going to just do a fun fact if
you don't back
I'm originally from Brooklyn and I play
drums in a hardcore band hi everyone
hello good afternoon my name is red
I'm from Globe Telecom I'm actually from
the Philippines Globe Telecom is one
right now is the leading
telecommunication in the Philippines
from service from wireless to wired to
all types of communication services
we're also venturing an entertainment
system solutions right now including
eSports and YouTube and everything else
I work as a digital workplace manager in
globe for about six years now almost six
years and I've been a GC customer for
that long period of time as well we're
trying to explore zcp and
yeah I'd love to you know share more
details to you guys later
great thanks very much Fred could we
advance the slide please
oh there it is thank you
so whoops there it is
so a quick reminder you've probably seen
this in previous sessions we are using
dory today so if you have a question
please feel free to add it to the Dory
as we go throughout the conversation and
we'll bring up some of the top questions
at the end of the session today Sam my
esteemed colleague here is actually
leading that effort and you'll hear from
him or save your questions for the end
and we'll bring them back on the mics so
question for y'all how many of you are G
suite admins today okay right yes my
test account at the very least great so
I expect you'll have some good questions
for this for this audience are good
questions for this panel I would love to
start this conversation by learning a
little bit more about our worldwide
panel's environment so starting with you
Pascal can you tell us about your
environment and how you're using G suite
today how many users you support what
does the day and the life look like for
you as an administrator and thinking
about that what's the biggest or most
unique security problem that you face so
basically at Vale yeah the jesuits story
started in 2012 basically we did a study
at that time because we wanted to
challenge the solution we had it which
was a Microsoft Office so we did that
study it didn't take so much time to
realize that we have to move to Jesuit
so it started in 2013 with whole core
services basically so we did the messy
rollout in all our business units just
for information we have like 60 business
units all over the world so as I said
before it's hundred and sixty thousand
people so how our concern about that
even though we don't have so many I
would say user accounts around one
hundred and hundred thousand so we have
three major concerns at that time which
were 2-step verification we wanted to
allow it account with the two-step
verification
because we are massively using single
sign-on and all our solution basically
rely on the strength of Google identity
so it's mandatory for us to have a
single sign-on in place and just a
verification and the third point is also
a tool that we have developed which is
called a Deema for digital identity
management
it's basically related to all our
accounts and the life cycle of our
employees when I get into the company
when they move when they yeah so it's
the whole challenge that we had to face
at that time and as for the
administration we are currently doing
something what we call our technical
depth but we will talk about that maybe
a little bit later and the idea behind
it is that since we massively rolled out
all those services we didn't pay so much
attention that just with security at the
beginning so now we have to let's say
get rid of this technical death and we
can detail this in few minutes so six to
seven hundred people far less than both
red and Pascal here but that said
they're dispersed throughout the world
we have offices in Berlin Toronto New
York and San Francisco as well as stores
all out there all throughout domestic us
some in Canada as well so supporting all
those users gets a little difficult I
would say the biggest thing or the
difficulty that we run into is as a
retail company you know with holidays
you know you have to hire and then
there's a lot of attrition in retail so
a lot of user accounts get provisioned
and then quickly deep revision so being
able to turn those accounts over quickly
is very critical for us which we've been
able to use G suite for aside from that
we use all the course G suite
functionality such as Drive Docs things
like that to collaborate with all of our
users in real time previous to that we
were using office 365 which is okay but
when you're trying to collaborate in the
last minute presentation for a board
meet
it gets a very difficult in PowerPoint
so slides makes that a bit easier pass
day in the life of myself I think we're
covering that yeah cool yeah Jana live
for us is we have IT stand-up in the
morning
starting with meditation it's five
minutes the team looked at me like I was
crazy when we started but honestly it's
super helpful just to get in a good
mindset for the madness that will ensue
throughout the rest of the day so we
start off with our s LA's we go through
our road map for the quarter for the
year to make sure we're all adhering to
the due dates that we've agreed to
meetings galore as I'm sure everybody
can attest to with all the difference
across functional partners that we have
to ensure that we're all aligned on the
rapidly moving targets of the business
and let's see unique security I think I
just already mentioned that with the
patrician
in retail so so with the globe were
actually about almost 18,000 employees
we're scattered across the Philippine
Islands that's about one seventy
thousand 107 depending on the tide
whether it's low rise or maybe rising
low tide but we've been a customer for
about six years now and as I mentioned
earlier we were using quite heavily on
GSP specifically on productivity drive
we've subscribe to unlimited storage and
all we've within those 17,000 workforce
majority of them if not she nodes but
probably around 9,000 regular employees
the other are temporary employees so
with that in mind that would be our
security concerns as well because we
have a unlimited storage of data and at
the same time we're scattered everywhere
with that since we're scattered a lot of
our concerns mostly in our devices and
all identity and you know making sure
it's self self-service in terms of
troubleshooting all of these things and
we're able to help rather fix out
through MDM cheesy MDM and it's quite
weird
because those that are not within our
not within our it's head office are
actually the more people they are the
most to adapt quickly rather than the
ones in the head office probably because
they're there they become self-reliant
and making sure that they're you know
follow instructions and all these things
so I guess that's a data life I've been
working for a globe for six years and
I'm handling apps and devices so every
every employee apps and employee devices
goes through me in terms of the approval
in terms of roadmaps and all of those
requirements so we've been trying to
move everything to the cloud and also to
mobile first so that's what I do every
day and also coordinate with our
security team we have our send command
center which basically monitors all our
network traffic specifically hunting one
of the largest network infrastructure in
the Philippines so yeah great so
thinking about this environment based on
your own experience there's a few things
I'll follow up on but I'll ask the big
question first which is if you're a G
suite ad then what is one thing you
should do right now to improve your
security and we'll start with you pesco
well as a cyber security officer I would
say when you roll out
Google service whatever it is with
service you have to think about the best
compromise between the basic experience
user experience and security risks so
what does it mean if you don't do that
what's going to happen you will generate
what we call a big technical depth I'll
give you some figures because as I
mentioned before when we started to run
out massively or Jesuit services we pay
attention that user first and we said
okay we want the bad experience for them
because we have also to convince that it
was the best choice that we did but we
didn't take care so much about security
at that time okay so now what we realize
is that I give you some figures we have
for instance 1,400 Google groups without
any manager Horner's site means we have
no idea about the spans for those groups
for instance we
over 100 domains internal domains which
are not compliant related to enticing so
we have to work about that we have also
some fingers related to pop/imap we have
thousand users who still beneficiate
from this service so the idea behind it
if I give you those figures that this
huge technical depth we have to solve
that so the best way to do it is of
course when you start is to put in place
some kpi's automatic ones because then
you put a process and you are able to
trust all what's going to happen and the
evolution about those services again
with a company like ours large-scale
company you've got to do that otherwise
everything is going to be under control
out of control sorry
and one other point is also to take the
good measure to to put the risk under
control and this is what we've been
doing note for quite some months and
it's hard and very painful to to go to
business unit and to say could you
please justify what you're still being
using this pop/imap which if you don't
have any business reason to use not
supposed to use that anymore at least
from a user perspective so it's a long
long journey but one also point we I
wouldn't mention here is which is quite
exceptional is to do it but little by
little I know it's takes quite a while
but if you think that you will you are
going to solve everything at once it is
not going to work so think about this
the best compromise between user
experience and security risk
good KPIs automatic ones and takes
action measure and put this process in
place you know that you aren't you have
another view about that Pascal I'd like
to follow up on that a little bit you
talked about using KPIs to measure
progress can you talk a little bit how
you use our tools or perhaps home built
tools to monitor those KPIs and keep an
eye on risk yes it's true we we've been
using also a Security Center like a -
Birds
I mean built-in dashboards quite useful
of course we have developed also some
what we call productivity tools in order
to check few things that we didn't have
natively with Google we're also using
investigation tool which
is quite powerful to where we could just
do some requests in order to have some
figures as I mentioned before we also
did we've been using also tools like
email log search also to confirm that
there's some traffic going some in some
SMTP relays for instance all those kinds
of things so it's both a compromise
between the native tools that Google
could provide and also the tools that we
have developed great Thank You Ryan
sure so I would say 2-step verification
two-factor authentication day1 turned it
on super important especially if you're
a larger company or a company of
interest or disrupter you know Casper
becomes a target for many other many of
our competition so you want to make sure
that we are taking the steps to mitigate
as many malicious attacks as possible to
start verification is a great way to
start doing that past that incident
management protocols super important you
don't really think of a plan of action
when something goes wrong until
something goes wrong and by then it's
too late and you're just operating on
adrenaline and it just turns into a big
mess
you know speaking from experience I've
done that before and learned a lot being
able to figure out the course of action
the parties that need to be notified the
notification schedule I'm having
templates of information that you're
sending out to the team you know with
some variables that you're changing
obviously so you're not reinventing the
wheel or writing an entirely new email
every time you deal with a security
issue I find that super important in
addition to that a change advisory board
is super helpful when you're looking to
implement changes having an established
change advisory board with influencers
in the company senior leadership you
want those people involved so when you
do recommend changes they are vetted
properly and then they become
essentially the people who are you know
again champion championing the change
for you so when it comes from the top
down
it's it's adopted much much quicker user
follow-up question for you Ryan
we talked a lot about security keys
we're very proud of the fact that
security keys can help you reduce the
risk of phishing reduce the risk of
account hijacking sometimes security
keys have a perception of being
difficult to use how did you overcome
that perception among your user
community that's a tough one so we're
still rolling out security keys to our
fleet but we do have a group of
outsource contractors as well as our
retail teams that are using security
keys on a daily basis now for new users
who aren't familiar with the protocols
of the company super easy just give them
a security key and tell them this is
what you do but when it's a user who's
used to how it was before it gets a
little bit more difficult explaining to
them the benefits of utilizing security
keys for 2-step authentication you know
there are other methods of the two-step
authentication as well obviously through
your phone Google Authenticator you know
there are third parties that do it too
but security keys I find is is a great
first step of of that two-factor
authentication not everybody's going to
be keen on carrying something around
with them all the time so having the
backup of a phone for that verification
process is helpful but we are working on
it on the corporate side for sure great
thank you
red what's the one thing every G suite
admin should do to improve their
security oh look at it end-to-end I
guess it's more of a because my role
actually looks at devices and
application so it's more of I can have a
enter invisibility with how the user
experience is I guess it's really more
of that so create a roadmap have a
specific solution each of the points
that you have to consider from the log
and experience to multi-factor
authentication to the MDM up until to
the SSO that you've implemented to your
application so it's something that we've
been working on over the last four years
and was trying to make sure that we've
have that in place also I'd like
that's true if I'm thinking I'm gonna
add in something what Ryan said earlier
having at a probably a change management
board and at the same time something to
do with our security posture right now
since we're a telco we have to comply
with our version of GD P R which is DPA
we utilize the DPA to make sure that we
have fundings if you we need to put more
you know security layers on top of what
we have right now so yeah use what you
have and also make sure you have that
roadmap in place what's the name of the
regulation again DPA so data privacy
yeah the DPA can you comment a little
bit about how you do your audits for DPA
and how you either how you use tools
from us as well as your own build tools
for that so we have we have plenty of
tools that were using from third-party
solutions to native Google solutions
such as security center from both DCP
and also with G suite but more so we
also have our internal teams who's
building gnarly sophisticated but more
of automating that flow from using
Splunk to different third-party
solutions yeah we usually we have
incidents security incidents that we can
actually use a security center to make
sure we check all the you know steps and
also the track the users usage in a
sense and that's how we utilize a G
speed security Center more of the alerts
as well actually earlier today I receive
an alert from the Centers they stating
that you know this specific account has
been you know probably be a phishing
account whatsoever but apparently one of
our security part of a security command
center team was actually testing that
functionality that's abuse at globe.com
a Pho basically it sends another to
everyone if we notice some sort of an
abuse for smtp relay or for any other
you know a activity cool got it great
thank you so
thinking about best practices I'm gonna
ask them you additional best practice
questions but what are some of the
pitfalls or blind spots or trouble spots
that you run into and how were you able
to overcome them in the last in the last
few years
well I start yes I keep only to respect
the order yes we don't have to go order
we can go in a different order by the
way this is you here let's let's ride
why don't you start okay we gotta change
it a little to orderly I'm confused
yeah well my initial answer was we
haven't really run into too many issues
yeah fingers crossed all those things
crossed I'm sure but as soon as I said
that place is on fire back in New York
but one thing that we've run into is
user authentication not two-factor and
nothing like that but third-party
services so a lot of people still use
usernames and passwords for a service
that is not directly related to G suite
the great thing about this and maybe I'm
getting ahead of myself a little bit is
what happens when you put me on the spot
using the native SSO services from G
suite to link that application or
service into G suite so an authentic
authentic AIT's through that mitigating
the need for username password
sometimes provisioning the user
automatically and D provisioning them
automatically that has alleviated a lot
of headache across the company where
people were either forgetting their
usernames or passwords
we're just signing up for services they
shouldn't be I mean gaining accesses to
access to services that they shouldn't
be let's go okay so failure we faced
nearly two years ago I think it was in
May 2017
a large-scale phishing attack directed
at basically Google customers so as a
classical phishing attack the users
received an email from an attackers who
pretended to be a contact of Adam and it
was a basically link to
an application which falsely claimed to
be a Google Doc and by this phishing
link it was supposed to access to user
account in order to basically steal all
contact information and then the idea
behind it was to say to send again this
message to all the contacts and so on so
Google did its job disabling all the
links removing the login page and so on
so what we have learned from that
basically is that first of all we can
use the customized settings from Google
we have some that we have applied at the
domain level like identifying links
behind the shortened URLs for instance
it's a bit technical but it's one a
feature you could put also related to
scan linked images things like that and
also some warning prompt when you click
on a link that goes to an interested
demand and all the sudden pops up a
warning which is quite efficient as well
so those are basically the tools that
Google can provide and you can put in
place the second part I would I would
mention is I come back to a point that
Ryan already talked about is related to
security keys so security keys it's
probably today the best second step
verification method that we have against
phishing better than prompt a twenty
cater and so on so I mentioned before
that it was one of the key point for
Veolia at that time in 2013 even though
we have evolved and the users we
recommend that they use prompt we have a
very sensitive population which are
super and min accounts so we have the
jesuits super admin accounts we have the
GCP super min accounts we have all the
cloud platform super and min accounts
and the third population is also all
super and means related to SAS solution
that we have integrated in our
environment I mentioned like for CRM HR
Payroll and so on and we have very
sensitive information so what we've done
so far we have identified those
population and we started to actually
create
a dedicated Jesuit account needless to
mention that some of them were using
their regular accounts in order to do
some sensitive action but I'm sure Billy
has not the only company behind between
us so we started to roll out security
keys so pay attention to one point and
maybe we can talk about that again later
at the security now that has been
provided by Google and the Titan key
with the Bluetooth mode is very user
experience very good as user experience
and nobody can claim that they have an
issue because the security cannot be
introduced in their chrome booths or
other devices and so on it does not work
anymore since it works contactless so it
which is quite good and the last point
is don't get don't give in to people who
come to you and says how you will have
but today I have I have forgotten my
security key you know it was much easier
with prompt our SMS you know I always
have my phone my telephone with me and I
tell them that when you go shopping you
take your credit card don't you and if
you just forget once your credit card
the second time sure you won't forget it
and it's the same with a security key
and this is what we have pinned I have
two things actually
one is MDM and the other one was SSO so
about all the three years ago so we've
started the venture of trying to
introduce MDM to our employees the thing
is we were kind of having a hesitation
from them specifically because it's
gotta be you know and on their device
first question was are you going to
check my personal files or all of these
things you know they're more conscious
and that's good there are more conscious
of what did what happens to their
accounts but it took them a while to
realize that you know it's better to
have the MDM in place rather than not so
there was a it was an event but three
years ago one of the guys actually one
of the top guys and globe lost their
phones while they were in Barcelona so
they're doing the MWC event so and they
were there and there was the first thing
that they did is actually the the
contacted me and it was a night time
here in Manila at the time and I had to
do something and I told them were you
did you enable MDM on your end or like
realtor set it up and they said yes and
I said yeah good thing because we were
able to lock the unfold what so ever and
that made actually he was the one who
championed the MDM across a globe so
because of that experience and we kind
of made sure that everyone knew about
what happened and in the leader circle
they were very well aware of what's
going to happen if they don't turn on
their MDM on their phones the second one
was the SSO so right now it is actually
because of the roadmap that we have for
the experience people are now focusing
on all their applications like they want
to have an SSO experience across all and
they want Google login there because
before a Google login there we have our
own internal solution I was supposed to
be doing that functionality but because
of you know obvious an old one and you
know it's not it's not something that
was able to accommodate all the
functionalities we would be requested
they're having a hard time logging and I
rather integrating their application to
that solution so it was it was something
that you know we wanted to push forward
so right now all of our software as a
service solutions they're all using
Google login and since then we don't
have we haven't experienced any you know
account compromised or whatsoever we
just made sure that everyone gets to FA
at the onset and we disabled those
things that should be disabled like for
example I am app and pop3 disabled under
at the start of the the account itself
occasion because that's a common theme
disabled IMAP and pop3 you can do that
with one check box by the way yeah I
noticed that a cup ryan and red you were
talking about enabling single sign-on to
third-party services using google cloud
identity where there are some barriers
or problems you had to overcome when you
did that with other user resistance or
difficulty with the services no no right
I guess everyone's familiar with the
Google login so it's it's a
they're using it in their own personal
accounts I guess what we did so that
it's gotta be it was easy for them was
to emulate how they do it in their own
accounts and that same way once we
enabled for example to FA and the SSO
they wanted to do it as well on their
own personal account so even there we
were able to influence them and made
sure that they're well aware of you know
security risk on their own space so yeah
well I noticed a couple cases where
you're actually your end user was a
security advocate your end user said hey
I was able to improve my security on my
own account or in the other case your
implementation of MDM was able to save
me a security risk personally so was
that a case where they were able to
actually be an advocate outside their
own throughout the organization yes also
for some odd reason these guys are
pretty thing that was babies as well I
mean we want to make sure that's one of
the mantra actually of data we want to
make sure that our employees are being
treated properly so instead of just
telling them exactly what to do we're
trying to influence them as well
that they have to do it on their own
personal space too so for example there
were cases before we're in facebook
accounts not even Google accounts
Facebook accounts and their own personal
space got compromised and we told them
to do enable to FA as well so it's not
really about just Google or whatsoever
it's about security posture across all
so at the end of the day the user
whether it's a personal space or a
company space would have the same
security risk right great
ok next question we would we wanted you
to share some tips and tricks things
that are things that you do that make
your your management experience with
Google a bit better or that save you
time while administering G suite
security read yeah read you read you
start this time well keep it simple what
we're doing is go for the native once if
we're not satisfied with it that we go
for to automate it and to to get
third-party solutions well as much as
possible we want to go for the native
solutions and try to lock as soon as
possible before we can
for example is that with the IMAP and
pop3 at the onset we had to disable it
and not just on G speed level but on the
network level so even if the
administrator you know mistakingly
turned on the IMAP and POP there's
certain floors in the building that's
really locked down across also you
cannot use your IMAP and pop3 also in
terms of I guess you have to make sure
you have user templates I like what they
write and we do that as well and globe
because we have a different security
team
we call them is DP so information
security and data privacy team and our
team is systems and Atmos Information
Systems Group so basically we work
hand-in-hand with them so there were
there's operations and at the same time
they maintained the policies but we're
more on focusing on the solution
implemented sure of the solution so as I
mentioned earlier the templates that we
guys collaborated with it was easy for
us to give awareness our employees the
point that probably they're sick of our
are innocent in terms of templates and
use cases and whatsoever but it was it
was helpful for us to you know veer them
away from the usual to more of a higher
security posture yeah tell me a little
more when you say security templates
what do you mean for example when you
when you have a new hacker news or
whatever issues we have a template
already that we can already use to
communicate fast that's once announced
like new upgrades or question ality
that's - the third one would be in terms
of requesting for security like for
example for SSO but you have to create a
project in GCP you have to integrate it
with with a project right for you to use
the API admin API of Google you have to
you know request it in a manner and you
have to explain what what what these
applications were the would request so I
would reduce the APS for so what we do
is to create that template make sure
that they file it properly to us and
it's been it's a collaborative template
actually so all of our
the personnel would be able to go
through that template and you know give
their advice whether we go through it
with it or not so yes for a failure
would say premature pillars and the
strip and tricks I see so we mentioned
it MDM yeah with the basic ones inside
like ping code screen locks and all that
stuff and again 2-step verification and
again you you really have to carry on
with this which is very important as we
mentioned before otherwise you can
explain to your user that they will have
to change the password on very very very
regular basis which can be a pain in the
neck so but may be a tip to maybe roll
out more broader this this kind of
2-step verification is first of all to
start with a scope that you have under
control people that you know some are
two key players that you have and you
start to discuss with them if they are
in fluent you can go and have meeting
with their team explaining why it's the
best way to do it and start to about
elaborate a clear and understandable
process like you identify the population
you distribute your keys you spend some
time with some users trying to set up
the keys with an within their hair
accounts and I mentioned before the
super and min accounts what you do is
and it's now available within Google you
say that this two step verification is
security key and only security key and
the second point is that you do not tip
the natural you tips are in a trusted
device it means that each time they log
in they have to play the security key no
other choice so this is really really
great for those sensitive account so
again I mean it is really basis but it
has to be implemented in order to
enforce security what I notice here is
that yeah but I what I notice here is
this as much as this is as much about
process and about organ is about putting
together an organizational approach that
gets people involved in securing their
own devices rather than just using the
technical solutions well it is correct I
mean
again at large-scale company like ours
in but I guess it's also a good
playground even with smaller company
there there is no other choice I mean if
you don't do that then it's gonna be a
total mess I mean I don't see any option
if you don't have a clear process
understandable process I couldn't agree
more Ryan yeah to a little bit more on
what Pascal mentioned earlier service
accounts for everything anything that
requires an admin login or you know
account to do something administrative
Li have a service account for it don't
tie it to a personal account and then
continuing along those lines team drives
is great Google team drives allows you
to tease it's here for Google team Joe
Watts for Team drive right yeah thanks
nice yeah so I'll just drop the mic
so yeah Google team drives is great
because it allows you to remove the
actual file from being attached to a
particular user the user leaves the
company those files don't go with them
although there are methods of getting
around that team drives is a great tool
that we are starting to implement across
the entire company to great success past
that automate as much as you can there
are so many things that we need to do as
administrators it's very tedious work
and as you scale I mean I'm only
speaking for myself
I'm sure the stage knows far more better
than I do about this but those processes
start to scale when you multiply them by
10 20 30 40 50 percent it just becomes a
nightmare so automate Google Apps Script
fantastic tool we use that for
onboarding and off-boarding so our HR
teams are able to enter information and
the relative name for the user or the
manager of the user the start date it's
a contract with the end date and then it
kicks off automation sending calor
difference to the hiring manager
creating the actual accounts we use a
third-party tool Carl called better
cloud which is a fantastic one that
integrates very tightly with G suite
that allows us to kick off workflows or
automation so it'll work with slack etc
and just create all the accounts we need
for day one whether you
starts very little interaction from our
part and then conversely when they leave
same situation it D prior or D
provisioning thank you so much Angela
yes deeper prioritize maybe prioritizes
after my work thought emitted but yeah
it removes everything and it just makes
life a lot easier and ensures it no user
her there so automation huge thing
really appreciate that with the
automation who here use this app script
on a regular basis oh cool
I think definitely want to definitely
want to highlight that I want to make
sure to allow some time for questions so
my last question to y'all and how are we
on the dory quite a few questions on the
dory excellent so my last question are
you've been looking at the door
excellent my last question for y'all is
what new security controls are you
looking forward to coming from G suite
that we don't have yet well especially
once in beta looks like yeah well first
two are the DLP but we know it's coming
because data loss prevention as long as
you know what you company what a
sensitive data means then it's great to
use such a tool but the first thing is
to define what a sensitive data yes
which is the first problem so but it can
be quite powerful
once you have such a tool the second one
is is related to maybe more mobility and
we have such a project within our
company secure anytime anywhere any
device
it means mobility everywhere and I'm
talking about context-aware
access and you can authorize some people
to access according to a certain context
to some resources and this is also a
very great tool that we we've been
assessing for a while and now Andrew
starts my shopping list
so actually we faced an issue which is
called API control we would like to get
more granular control related to api's
versus demand wide delegation I said
before that we try to integrate more
assess solution and those solution they
tend to consume some
Sushi's Jesuit service resources like
calendars drives and so on and they ask
for them in why delegation so again at a
company like ours at scale it means
accessing the whole domain so we would
like more granular things like this
another tool we could be great we
discussed before sensitive accounts
super naming accounts is one category
but we are also all the dedicated and
means and we have customer customized
wrong and one of the problem is that
some they use some roles but sometimes
it don't use it it would be so great to
have a tool that could say like a guy
now you not you are not using this
customized role for now three month ok
this is the list we would like to get
rid of this custom role because it's
well you don't need it it still this
privilege and we don't have such a tool
and it would be great to have that ok ok
I have some other idea like management
API I mean I mentioned we are thousand
organizational units ok and it's quite
difficult to have an idea about the
security of it has been implemented just
in one click so it would be great to
have a report right away to say old I
look in this exactly Isis should I carry
an Andrew should I thank you I think we
Ryan and red and I can't make any
commitments to anything new but please
watch out for the beta's so I'm looking
forward to being able to share drive
data with external non gmail orgy speed
partners that's really exciting for us
we do work with tons of vendors that
force us to use another service which
will remain nameless but we are still
utilizing two different file sharing
services which causes some confusion
within the company on what to store
we're past that MDM the functionality
for like Chrome OS Android iOS fantastic
and point verification is a thing for
Windows and Mac I'm really excited to
see where that goes down the line if we
can you know kind of consolidate the
other management tools that were using
currently
which will I guess also remain nameless
it would be great to I'll do that all
from within G suite because it does it
really well yeah that's that's the only
two things I want right now Thank You
red yeah and when Maya and actually
you've said a lot of you know requests
but yeah particularly is the context
aware I know it's in beta already I
haven't tested out what went out but
context-aware basically it's more of and
I've actually one of the questions here
was locking down specific access to a
specific location whether it's through
an IP or a specific time that would be
great because we have a lot of temporary
employees as well those we want to make
sure that they're only using it on a
specific location
another thing it'd be against more on
the drive as well under an Team drive
yeah that's one of the particular
concerns because we are collaborating
with different Google user G's with
users so we want to make sure that we
can still collaborate with them but at
the same time would remain the files
would remain with us and will not be you
know destroyed whatsoever once the
person is you know cut out from our
organization that's the one point is
related to extension also Chrome
extension yeah whatever it's it's an
issue for us because users they use them
a lot and we acquired I have no
visibility if we could have a tool to
have more say easy to whitelist things
like that you know
[Music]